The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good morning.
This is 600.
So I hope any of you who thought
this was a different
course find where you
really belong.
My name is John Guttag.
And I'll be lecturing the
course all semester.
OK.
Today I want to accomplish
several things.
Cover some of the administrative
details.
Talk about the goals
of the course--
what I hope you'll learn.
And then begin talking
about the conceptual
material in the course.
It will seem a little bit slow,
because it will be a
little bit slow.
I promise starting on Thursday
we're going to pick up the
pace considerably.
So let's start with the
strategic goals of the course.
The official introduction
to course 6 is 601.
Historically, students who
arrive at MIT with little or
no programming experience
find 601 an ordeal.
And the point of this is
to prepare freshman and
sophomores for entering
course 6--
that's the Electrical
Engineering Computer Science
department--
in a gentler, kinder way.
So that 601 is not so
much of a problem.
I want to help students
feel justifiably--
and I want to emphasize
the word justifiably--
confident in their ability
to write small and
medium sized programs.
So at the end of the term, you
should all feel comfortable
writing programs.
The real theme of the course,
and what I spend most of the
time on, is how to map
problems into a
computational framework.
There's going to be an emphasis
on scientific
problems, rather than, say,
commercial problems.
But there will be some talk
about some non-scientific
problems as well.
How to take a problem that may
not at first blush appear to
be attackable with the program,
and show you how to
formulate the problem in such
a way that you can use
computation to get insight
into the problem.
It should not take
you very long.
All of the problem sets involve
programming in Python
programming language, which I'll
say a little bit about
later today.
The first problem set,
basically, is getting Python
installed on your
own computer.
Most of the people will want to
just use whatever their own
laptop is to do the
problem sets on.
Don't get fooled by the first
two problem sets into thinking
this is a gut course.
It's not.
It starts out gently
to lure you in.
And then life gets pretty
hard pretty quickly.
So don't be fooled.
The quizzes--
and there will be two evening
quizzes and a final--
are open book open notes.
When you get to be my age, you
get very sensitive about how
difficult it is to
remember things.
And so, we won't be asking
you to memorize stuff.
The course is about solving
problems, knowing how to solve
problems, not how much
you can remember.
For many of you who are majoring
in biology or course
20, it's going to be kind of a
shock that this course isn't
about how much you can remember,
but it's about how
well you can solve problems.
And that's what the quizzes
are really going
to be focused on.
Probably the most unusual thing
about this course is the
collaboration policy, which
is liberal in the extreme.
You can collaborate with anybody
you want on any of the
problem sets.
Not on the quizzes.
But on any of the
problem sets.
You can work with each other,
which is what I recommend.
You can work with your parents,
if one of them
happens to be a software
engineer.
You can work with friends
in course 6.
Whatever you want to do.
The goal of the problem sets
is to help you learn.
What we've seen in the past is
people who are a little, shall
I say too collaborative, i.e.
they just copy the problem set
from somebody else, live in a
fool's paradise which comes
crashing down at
the first quiz.
People who don't spend enough
time thinking about the
problem sets themselves cannot
take the quizzes successfully.
So it's a fine line.
But our goal is not
to be policemen.
I tell my TAs, their job is to
help you learn, not to prevent
you from, quote, cheating.
So to solve that problem, we've
eliminated the concept
of cheating on problem sets.
There is no way to cheat
on problem sets.
So just go and do them.
There's no textbook.
We will be posting readings
on the web.
For the most part, these will
be pointers to websites.
Occasionally we'll
post readings
that we wrote ourselves.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't
buy a textbook.
In fact, there are a number
of Python texts.
We'll recommend a few of them.
It might make sense to buy one
and bring it to a quiz,
because it will have an index
that will let you look things
up quickly, that
sort of thing.
But again, a lot of students
never buy a
text and do just fine.
We will not be handing
out class notes
on a regular basis.
A lot of studies have indicated
that students learn
more when they take their own
notes than when they are
handed out.
And so, as a matter of what I
think is good pedagogy, we
don't hand out detailed
lecture notes.
We will be using, after today, a
lot of handouts with code on
them, which we'll
make available.
But it's not intended to make
any sense outside the context
of lectures.
It's not self-contained.
The main purpose of this course
is to help you become
skillful in making the
computer do what
you want it to do.
Once you acquire this skill,
your first instinct, when
confronted with many tasks, will
be to write a program to
do that task for you.
I always tell people I became
a computer scientist in part
because I'm lazy.
And there was a lot of stuff
that I found it was easier to
write a program to make
the computer do it,
rather than do it myself.
So I do that a lot.
If I need to do something, I
say, can I just write a quick
program to do it?
And I'd like you to be able
to acquire that skill.
And remember, that programming
is actually a lot of fun.
So I should say that, in
addition to learning a lot in
this course, I hope most of
you will find it fun.
Kind of a strange thought.
MIT course, fun.
Maybe it's an oxymoron.
But I don't think so.
I really do think you can have
a lot of fun writing programs
for this course.
There are many people
who believe that--
how shall I say this?
Programming is the most
fun you can have with
your clothes on.
It really can be a lot of fun.
So think of it that way.
All right.
So the primary knowledge you're
going to take away is
computational problem solving.
So to start with, we might
ask the question, what is
computation?
And to think about that--
this is interesting.
Ah, there's where
the chalk is.
I was afraid I was going to be
confronted with a sea of black
boards and erasers
and no chalk.
But there is chalk.
So if we think about it,
there are essentially
two kinds of knowledge.
Declarative--
and you're going to see, I'm
not a great speller.
And imperative.
Declarative knowledge
is composed of
statements of fact.
For example, a good health care
plan improves the quality
of medical care while
saving money.
As we know from doings in
Washington, it's a lot easier
to state that goal than to know
how to achieve that goal.
So the key thing about
declarative knowledge is, it
says something that is true.
Otherwise it wouldn't be
knowledge, it would be
misinformation.
But doesn't tell you
how to do it.
In a more mathematical sense,
say y is the square root of x
if and only if y times
y equals x.
All right?
Perfectly clear statement of
what it means to be the square
root, but it doesn't tell you
how to find the square root.
Interestingly enough, it does
tell you how to test whether
or not you have the answer
to the square root.
And so if you had some way of
generating guesses, you can at
least check whether
they're correct.
And in fact, starting in the
next lecture, we'll talk about
the fact that a lot of
computational techniques
involve something called
guess and check.
Where you have a way to generate
guesses and a way to
check whether they're right.
Imperative knowledge, in
contrast, tells you how to
solve a problem.
How to accomplish something.
So you could think of it as like
a recipe in a cookbook.
So it's one thing to say a
chocolate cake is something
that tastes delicious
and is bad for you.
That's declarative knowledge.
But you can open a cookbook and
get a recipe that tells
you how to make a
chocolate cake.
That's imperative knowledge.
Now, below, we have a recipe for
finding not a square root
necessarily, but an
approximation to a square root.
And one of the themes of this
course is that a lot of
problems we cannot solve
precisely, but we can find
answers that are good enough
for practical purposes.
And those are called
approximation algorithms.
So here's a way--
this is a very old method for
finding the square root.
In fact, it's believed
that Heron was
the one who did this.
Heron of Alexandria.
In the news much today,
Alexandria was the capital of
ancient Egypt.
He was the first one to
write this method
down a long time ago.
Though it's believed that even
before Heron, the Babylonians
know how to do it.
So you start with a guess, g.
Any old guess will do.
Then you say, is g times
g close enough to x?
If so, you stop.
Say OK, I've got a good enough
approximation of the answer.
If it's not, you create a new
guess by averaging g and x
divided by g.
So g new is going to be
g old plus x divided
by g old, over 2.
And then using this new guess,
you go back to step 2.
So let's quickly run through
an example of this.
We can start with this
pretty easily.
We'll take a guess.
Let's say g equals 3.
So we look at three times 3.
9.
And we say, is that
good enough?
Well, let's say we're looking
for the root of 25.
I guess I should have started
with the problem statement.
Sorry about that.
Well, 9 is probably not close
enough to 25 that we're happy.
May be good enough for
government work, but not for
most other purposes.
So we'll reset g, and we'll
set g to 3 plus 25 over 3.
All of that over 2.
Which equals 5.6666 et cetera.
All right.
So now we'll multiply
that by itself.
And that gets to
be about 32.04.
Close enough to 25?
Probably not.
So we'll take another step.
And we'll set g equal to--
well, when we're done with it
all, I'm not going to bore you
with writing the
formula again.
It'll be 5.04.
If we square that, it's 25.4.
We decide that's close enough
to 25, and we're done.
What we say at this point
is that the algorithm--
and that's an important word.
An algorithm is a description
of how to perform a
computation.
We say that the algorithm
has converged.
Which is a fancy way
to say it's halted.
What we've got here, if you
think about it, is a set of
instructions.
Steps that can be executed
and a flow of control.
The order in which
we execute them.
So if we look at this, there's a
default order of execution--
1, 2, 3, 4.
But then there's the go back
to step 2 and start over.
And there's a termination
condition.
It tells us when to stop.
And of course, that's
important.
I've always been amused, if you
look at a shampoo bottle,
you'll see an algorithm that
says something like lather,
rinse, repeat.
And if you follow it
literally, you
never get to stop.
Which I suppose make sense if
you're selling shampoo,
because people use
a lot of it.
But really, there
ought to be some
termination condition there.
OK.
So now, how do we capture this
idea of a recipe in a
mechanical process?
One way would be to design a
machine specifically to do
square roots.
So if I knew how to design
circuits, which I don't, I
could sit down-- probably many
of you could sit down--
and design a circuit that would
implement this algorithm.
And in fact, that's more or
less what you'll find in a
cheap four function calculator
that does square roots.
Not quite this algorithm, but
a similar algorithm is just
part of the circuitry
to go compute that.
And in fact, this used
to be the way that
all computers worked.
So the initial computers
were what are called
fixed program computers.
They were designed to do very
specific things, and that's
what they did.
So for example, one of the very
first computers, designed
in 1941, by Atanasoff and
Berry, solved systems of
linear equations for the purpose
of plotting artillery
trajectories.
And that's all it did.
If you wanted to balance your
bank account with this
computer, you couldn't do it.
But you could figure
out how to drop an
artillery shell somewhere.
Also during World War II, Alan
Turing built a machine
specifically designed
for breaking the
German enigma code.
Actually a fascinating story of
science how that was built.
But again, that was
all it could do.
These computers were useful,
but only in a
very limited way.
The big breakthrough, the thing
it made computation
really important to society,
was the invention of the
stored program computer.
It took people quite a while
to figure this out.
But once they did,
it seems obvious.
The basic notion of a stored
program computer is that the
instructions are the
same as data.
So now, there is no distinction
between the
program that implements the
algorithm and the data on
which that program operates.
So there's no difference between
the input of 25, part
of the data, and the steps of
the algorithm used to do that.
Once that was possible,
the machines
became infinitely flexible.
You could change the program
anytime you wanted.
And furthermore, programs
could produce programs.
Because programs can
produce data.
And if program and data are
the same thing, that means
programs can produce programs.
And we were off and running.
And that's really what made
computers what they are today.
Once this became clear as the
paradigm for computers, people
began to think of the computer
itself as a program.
And in particular, as a kind
of program called an
interpreter.
And we'll get to more
on this later today.
An interpreter is a program that
can execute any legal set
of instructions.
And consequently, can be used
to describe and accomplish
anything you can do
with a computer.
So roughly speaking, this is
what a stored program computer
looks like.
This is 6004 in 40 seconds.
It's got memory.
Lots of it today.
A control unit that basically
tells it what to do.
For example, fetch some data
from memory, put some data
into memory, send some output
to a screen, all of those
kinds of things.
What for historical reasons we
call the arithmetic logic
unit, this is, in some sense,
the brains of the computer.
The thing that actually
does computations.
An accumulator, which
is part of the
ALU that stores results.
And a bunch of input
and output devices.
The things that we actually see
when we use a computer.
And that's it.
And again, the key thing to
notice is, there's only one
kind of memory.
There's not a memory for program
and a memory for data.
There's just the memory.
The nice thing to think about
here is, given a small set of
instructions, you can
then build any kind
of program you want.
So typically, the computers have
a very small number of
built-in instructions.
Order of dozens,
and that's it.
And by combining those
instructions in very clever
ways, you can do arbitrarily
complex things.
In much the same way a good
chef can take a very small
number of ingredients, and from
those, produce a variety
of interesting edibles.
Alan Turing, in the 1930s--
very famous British
mathematician of whom you will
hear more--
showed that, in fact, there
were six primitive
instructions.
Each of which operated on
one bit of information.
And with those six primitive
instructions, you could do
anything that could be
done with a computer.
Kind of amazing.
It was six instructions.
There were things like
read, write, plus--
I don't know, maybe minus.
I forget what they were.
And that was it.
That's all you needed.
We will not make you write
programs using only six
instructions.
We will give you a
much larger set.
But still, it's really
quite remarkable.
It's what makes programming
such an amazing endeavor.
OK.
So what instructions
will you be using?
Well, that's what a programming
language does.
So a programming language
provides a set of primitive
instructions.
A set of primitive control
structures.
So instructions and mechanisms
for controlling the order in
which they get executed.
And that's all.
And then you can do whatever
you want with them.
And what distinguishes one
programming language from
another is what these
things are.
What are your instructions?
What of your flow of control?
And how do you combine them?
What are the combining
mechanisms?
And in fact, it's the combining
mechanisms more than
anything else that separate
one language from another.
The most amazing thing
about programming--
and this has its good side and
its bad side, and it's
something you need to remember
as you do the problem sets--
is that the computer will always
do exactly what you
tell what to do.
It's remarkable.
You don't have any friends
who will do whatever you
tell them to do.
I can tell you my children
certainly don't do whatever I
tell them to do.
And my wife doesn't either.
Sometimes she probably
thinks I do whatever
she tells me to do.
But a computer will do what
you tell it to do.
So that's very empowering.
It's also very annoying.
Because it means if your program
doesn't work, it's
your own darn fault.
You got nobody else to
blame but yourself.
Because it's not the
computer's fault.
You may want to curse the
computer, but you shouldn't.
It's just doing what
you told it to.
So be careful what
you wish for.
All right.
The programming language we're
going to use in 600 is Python.
It's a relatively recent
addition to
the universe of languages.
I want to emphasize that
this course is not
about learning Python.
I will spend relatively little
time in the lectures telling
you about Python.
It's about computational
methods, is what this course
is really about.
And Python is merely
a teaching tool.
Once you learn to program in
Python, it's easy to learn to
program in another language.
It's a very easily transferable
skill.
If we think about what defines
any programming language, it's
got a syntax, a static
semantics, and a semantics.
Are any of you here linguistics
majors?
Not a one.
All right.
Then I can make up whatever I
want about these terms and
maybe you'll believe me.
All right.
So the syntax tells us which
sequences of characters and
symbols constitute a
well-formed string.
So it would tell us, maybe, that
we could write something
like x equals 3 plus 4.
And that's syntactically
correct.
It's well-formed.
It might also tell us that
x equals 3 blank 4 is not
syntactically correct.
It's not a legal string.
So by analogy with English,
the syntax describes which
strings of words constitute
well-formed sentences.
Well-formed.
Not necessarily meaningful.
So it would tell you that some
sentence like Susan is
building is syntactically
well-formed.
It may not be very sensible.
The static semantics tells
us which well-formed
strings have a meaning.
That are which strings
are meaningful.
So you can think about that
as also making sense.
So in Python, it might tell us
that some strings which are
syntactically fine don't
mean anything.
So for example, it might tell
us that the string 3 divided
by the character string abc is
syntactically well-formed
because it's value
operator value.
Sort of like noun verb
noun is syntactically
well-formed in English.
But it would tell us
that there's no
real meaning to this.
Dividing a number by a string
doesn't mean anything.
And so you would get an error
message saying the syntax is
OK, but the static semantics
is broken.
So for example, in English ,
the sentence I are big is
somehow syntactically
well-formed--
noun verb noun--
but we might say it fails the
static semantic test.
We don't want to assign
a meaning to it.
The semantics of the language
looks only at the strings that
are both syntactically correct
and static semantically
correct, and assigns a
real meaning to them.
In natural language, sentences
can be ambiguous.
So one of my favorites, when I
have to write a recommendation
letter for a student that maybe
I don't think is so
good, I might say something
like I cannot praise this
student too highly.
Well, you can interpret
that however you want.
It keeps me from getting sued,
but I can also claim, well, I
don't like the student at all.
And English is full
of those things.
Programming languages, in
contrast, are designed so that
every well-formed program
has exactly one meaning.
There's no ambiguity.
So you can't typically
talk of a program as
having a semantic error.
If it is well-formed, it
means something, and
that's what it means.
On the other hand, it's easy
to talk about a program
meaning something other than
you wanted it to mean.
And you will discover in the
problem sets, most of the time
the programs don't mean what
you want them to mean.
That is to say, when you run
them, they don't give you the
correct answer.
And then you will go through
this process of debugging them
and learning how to do it.
So what might happen when we
write a program that doesn't
do what we want it to do?
It might crash.
By that, we mean stop running
and produce some palpable
indication that it
has done so.
So you've all used programs
that have crashed, right?
You sat there using your email
program or Word, or
PowerPoint, or something.
And suddenly, it
just goes away.
And you get a message on your
screen and an invitation to
send Apple or Microsoft a file
explaining what went wrong so
they can fix it.
In a properly designed computing
system, when one
program crashes, it does not
damage the overall system.
So you'd like it to
just be local.
What else might it do?
It might never stop.
Now, if you have no idea how
long a program is supposed to
run, this can be hard
to diagnose.
But again, I'm sure you've
all run into this.
I've certainly run into it.
Every once in a while I'll
say, try and write a
PowerPoint file.
And it'll just sit there.
Or I'll try to read a file and
it'll just sit there and never
finish the job.
Or I don't have enough
patience.
But probably it would never
have finished it.
Again, you will all write
programs that do this.
It's a good idea to know how
long you expect your programs
to run, so that you can
recognize this.
Typically, we say that these
programs have in them an
infinite loop.
And we'll talk about that when
we get to flow of control.
Finally, a program might run to
completion and produce the
wrong answer.
These problems are kind of in
ascending order of badness.
If it crashes, at least
you know that
something has gone wrong.
An infinite loop can be very
annoying, because you just
wait for a long time.
But the worst thing that happens
is when you think
everything is good
and it's not.
There have been lots of
examples of this.
This is the sort of thing
that costs lives.
There was a radiation therapy
machine that produced the
wrong dosage of radiation and
actually killed quite a few
people, because they put in
the correct input, and it
would dose the patient
with radiation.
And a fatal dose of radiation.
That's a really bad mistake.
There are buildings that
collapse because people run
programs that do the structural
engineering, and
the programs give the
wrong answer.
Lots of bad things can happen.
So one of the things we're going
to spend time on this
term is, what you can do to
avoid writing programs that
have this rather unpleasant
property.
How do you test them?
How do you write them in such
a way that this is the least
likely event?
That's not what you
want to happen.
OK.
Some programming languages
give you a lot of help in
avoiding these things.
Python is kind of mediocre
in that respect.
It's not the best.
It's not the worst.
It's somewhere in the middle.
Because what you'd like is a
program with very rigorous
static semantics, such that if
you pass those tests, it has a
high probability of behaving
as expected.
So for example, it's a good
thing that Python doesn't
allow you to do this.
Because who knows what
that's going to do?
Something weird.
You'd rather be told no,
you can't write that.
And then you have to write
something that's more
obviously meaningful.
Rather than it just making
up an interpretation.
As we will see going forward,
Python is not, for example, as
good as Java is at weeding
out meaningless things.
Or things that have surprising
meanings.
On the other hand, it's better
than C. So kind of in the
middle as these programming
languages go.
Why do we use Python in this
course if it's not the best in
that respect?
It's got several
good features.
One of them is, it's
easy to learn.
It's much less complicated
than, say, Java.
So the learning curve
is much steeper.
That's a good thing.
You get up to speed faster.
It's very widely used today in
a lot of areas of science,
particularly the
life sciences.
It has probably become the
most popular language in
biology and the other
life sciences.
And therefore, for those of you
who have careers in that
area, it's the most useful
language to know.
It's also widely used in
other areas as well.
It is easier to debug
than most languages.
And the reason it's easier to
debug than most languages, or
than many, is it's an
interpreted language.
So you'll remember, I talked
about a computer as an
interpreter.
Something that you feed in a
bunch of instructions, called
the source code.
You do some checking.
And then it executes the
instructions, including the
flow of control instructions.
Produces some output.
The nice thing that goes on
there is if something untoward
happens, the interpreter can
describe in the language of
the source code what
went wrong.
The source code is the
code that you wrote.
On the other hand, the way a
compiler works is, you take
the source code, you check it,
but then you translate it into
another language called
the object code.
This is a language closer
to the language that the
computer, the hardware, knows
how to interpret.
Then the hardware interpreter
interprets the compiled code,
the object code, and
produces output.
And the problem here is if
something goes wrong, it wants
to give you an error message in
terms of the object code,
which you've never seen
in your life.
And that can make
it very obscure.
So the advantage?
Why do we have compilers?
Typically, compiled languages
are more efficient.
Because they go through this
extra step, they take less
time to run those programs.
You can compile Python as well,
if you want to get an
efficient version.
But it's not designed under
that assumption.
And so, it works well when
it's interpreted, which
is why we use it.